Mark: So we don't know exactly how many shirts we got here
But I'm just going to keep putting them on until I literally can't put on any more or we run out of them
Bob:  They're just not like fitted shirts. Mark: Yeah.
But you mean these cheap bulk shirts aren't fitted?
Bob:  Shirts that you buy by the pound aren't tailored? Mark: EXCUUUUUSE you. How could you treat me-
Oh, God that hood is going to be so uncomfortable.
Bob: Oh, you can take that off.
Mark: No, no, no.
Bob:  You look like a huge hunch-back.
Mark: I'm already committed.
Bob:  Also you look like you're here to paint the house 'cause your wearing white sweatpants with white shirts.
Mark: (giggles)
Oh hell yeah. Alright, we got these fashionable V-necks. Oh the V's getting deepe- dee- (laughs)
Bob:-deepest- If I were you, I'm just here like- Veeeee-neck
Mark: Hell yeah, right down to the balls...
Bob: that'd be a B-neck...
Mark: Thanks man.. Thi- This is- This is already getting uncomfortable..
Bob: That's good.
Mark: I'm only fi- four  shirts in five with this.. Oh.
Amy: How's it going? I like the white on white.
Mark: Thanks.
Kathryn: You wanna peep with me? Amy: I'm peepin
Mark: *grunting*
Bob: Let me take...
Mark: My hair dick was gettin' in the way..
Alright, for those of you just joining, we don't know what we're doing, but here we go.
Bob:  Mark is putting on a lot of shirts.
Mark: Yeah, I'm up to seven.  I think?  Eight maybe? *Katheryn sneeze*
Bob:  I think that was eight...
Mark: Someone out there if you're in the chat, count with me cause I think we're..
...I think we're losing track of it..  It's getting a little harder to BREATHE...
Bob: *chuckling*
We're still okay.
Amy: Are we gonna have to cut you out of this?
Bob:  Probably.. (laughing)
Bob: *sarcastic* Good thing we planned.. We definitely out scissors somewhere convenient?
Mark: *laughing* Yeah.
Bob: All right so after that shirt it's 12.
Can I like punch you in the chest as hard as possible?
Mark: Not right now..
It's still gonna hurt..
Bob: *laughing*
Amy: Thicc.
Mark: Oh, man... Who knew Mark was soooo thicc
Kathryn: ...with Mark's thicc torso.
Mark: *laughing*
Amy: Thicc chest.
Mark: I've got...
Bob: No, these aren't...
Mark: the THICKEST chest
Amy: Oh geez.
Mark: Oh, sorry!
Kathryn: *laughing*
Mark: Oh good, crew. Cover up the "V" it's getting too fashionable in here..
Bob: The seven layered "V" *laughing*
Mark: So this is 12, this is 12.  This is a thick twelve. *laughing*
Amy: Thiiiick
Mark: Thank you.
Bob:  We have a lot more to go...
Mark: I'm hoping these are stretchy...
Bob:  Nope, they're non-. They're 100% Polyester.
Mark: AWH
Mark: *grunting while putting on the shirt*
*background laughing*
Got it. Nailed it. 13.
*Marks sighs*
Bob: This is a...
Amy: You look like a marshmellow.
Mark: Thank you!
Bob: This is a pack of nine more...
Kathryn: I love Ghostbusters!
Mark: Okay...
Bob: So after this you'll be on 21.
Mark: I can do 9.
Ugh...I may need help...pulling...down!
Amy: Yeah, whenever you're...
*Bob laughing*
Mark: Amy, if you could, like...
Amy: I'll stay at your back.
Mark: Yeah, just get the back and just, like tug it.
As hard as you can.
Kathryn: HMMM!  A good tug?
Bob: This is -uh- This is quality content.
Amy: Give you a TUG
Mark: grunting*
Amy: Yeah, there we go.
Mark: Oh man!  HOA
Bob: It's already funny. This is going to be funny for, like, the next half hour.
Mark: Is it?  When does it get sad?  'Cause I don't know...
Amy: Oh!  You're so...
Kathryn: Right?
Amy: You're real squooshy.
*Mark and Bob laughing*
Bob: Can you shake your belly yet?
Mark: Let me see...NOPE.  It is solid!
It's my pits that are starting to dig in.
*Bob and Kathryn giggling*
Mark: Hoo man!
Bob: You're really- you're really refining your "dad bod"
Amy: You should have gone for the, uh, the sleeveless...
Mark: It's getting WaaAAAAAAAARRRM
*all laughing*
Amy: We can give you the ice sticks!
Mark: No, that's at 80!
Kathryn: *with Mark* 80!
Mark: That's HOURS away!
Bob: We'll just rush up to 80
Mark: *interrupting* OOOH GOD!
Ugh!  that's some sweat *exhales*
Bob: It-It might get to the point soon where you're gonna want to do the old-
"you just stick your arms up and someone is like..."
Kathryn: *with Bob* Arms up?
Amy: yeah
*Mark laughing*
Mark: That's what it's going to have to be after a while...
Amy: Yeah, you know...whenever you're ready we can...
Mark: No, no, I can *struggling* still do it
*everybody talking at once*
Bob: -rolled up on your huge hunch-back
Mark: Let me DO it GUYS!  Let me DO it!
Amy: Show 'em your profile.
*Bob laughing*
Mark: Let me DO it *starts laughing* guys.
*everybody starts laughing*
Mark: here, let me get the black here...
Amy: A Mark-mellow!
Mark: Let me DO it guys!
Amy: Yeah!  You're a Mark-mellow!
Mark: I'm a Mark- *laughs*
*deep voice* I am the THICKEST
Bob: Alright...here we go.
*Mark grunting*
Bob: These are- these are XLs that we're into now.
Kathryn: Whoo!
Bob: Oh my god, that's a lot bigger...
Amy: Thanks for donating!
Mark: *exhales* Thank you.
I needed this: a little bit of reprieve before we get down!
*Bob laughing*
Mark: Oof
Bob: Ah, there we go.  That-that looks like it fits you perfectly!
Mark: Ah!
Bob: It's loose!
Mark: That's a QUALITY fit!
*Bob laughing*
Mark: Oh!  I'm stylish!  *starts laughing*
Bob: My favorite thing is your neck.  You can just see, like, the shadow around your neck.
*all laughing*
*laughing* It's just...you have...a 2 inch long neck that's surrounded by...
Mark: Ugh!  Has anybody been keeping track in the chat?  I have no idea.
Amy: We can ask them.
Bob: I know how many-how many are in each bag.
Mark: yeah?
Bob: So at the end of the larges, you have 21.
Mark: Okay.
Bob: This is a bag of 7 more.
Bob: So you're about to be at 28.
Amy: Okay, do you want us to just start putting them on you?
Mark: I GOT it.
Amy: *talking* -down...
Mark: OH HO!
Amy: *laughing* Oh no!
Mark: You just, like, PULLED me down with it.
Oh, the gel is just squooching up my face.
*All laughing*
Ah, it's just dripping!  Oh boy...
There we go, all right. I'll try to go faster. Oh geez. Sorry.
Kathryn: Oh, V-neck!  Sweet!
Mark: OOH!
Bob: You get to go back to being fashionable.
Mark: Hell yeah.  *addressing chat* Too pretty!  Hoo boy...
*laughing* "27", people are saying.
Bob: People are counting in chat
Mark: Oh yeah!
OH!
Bob: All right, so that's 28 shirts.
*Mark catches his breath*
Bob: There's another pack of seven.
Amy: Oh, your poor...okay.
Bob: Yeah, make sure-
Amy: This-we hadn't considered this part.
Mark: What?
Kathryn: The sleeves are all bunching.
Bob: *overlapping* Make sure the sleeves come down so they don't pinch your arms off.
Mark: It's too late...I'll lose all blood...
Amy: No, hold on, hold on, we weren't...
Oh my god, it's so sweaty in there!
*All laughing*
Bob: Can I punch you yet?
Amy: *To Kathryn* We gotta get the sleeves...
Mark: It's so...
Hang on, not yet.  I still got a little transfer going on here. You can punch me when they're all on.
Amy: It's so sweaty...
Mark: Is it possible to DIE?  Like this?
Amy: Probably, yeah.
Bob: Circulation loss is a serious concern.
Mark: *exhalation*
Mark: Keep going!  I'm a strong boy!
*All giggling*
Mark: Don't make fun of my HUNCH!
Amy: There is a hunch!
Kathryn: There's a hood down there, at the base level
Amy: Oh there is a hood!
Bob: Yeah he kept his hood on
Mark: Yeah, I didn't want to take my shirt OFF; this the put shirt ON challenge!
Amy: More out maybe?
Mark: Well, I don't know if that's going to help...
Bob: Just...and then lift them up, and then pull it down over your-
*Mark fails and struggles to recover*
*Bob and Kathryn laughing in sync*
Mark: oooHHHHH!
*Mark grunting, others laughing*
Bob: *laughing* Was that better?
Mark: *indignant* NO it was not BETTER
*all laughing*
In what world would that have been better?
Oh man...Oh GEEZ
Amy: Can you breathe?  Are you okay?
Mark: Yeah, I'm fine, don't worry about me.
Bob: Alright...
Mark: It's only just going to get, like, "Oh, it's hot."
Bob: Alright, try it- try it like this.
Mark: Yeah, that might work out better...
Bob: And then...
Mark: Oh JESUS
*Bob is wheezing at this point*
Mark: That's not better!  Oh god!   You guys are not helping!
Amy: Your head is too big!
Mark: You're going to CHOKE me on my collar.
Bob: Alright, well then maybe you just keep doing it your way and then we'll pull them down.
Bob: I'll pull- I'll pull one side...
Mark: *interrupting* I don't think I- I LITERALLY don't think I can anymore.
Kathryn: My entire foot is asleep.
Mark: Hey guys...this is how- this is how thick I stand right now.
Hey.
*To Amy* Pretty lady.  Wanna go on a date?
Amy: *overlapping* You're so thick!
Mark: Thank you!  Glad you noticed.
Amy: *to Kathryn* Get up!
Kathryn: *grunts* I can do it!
Mark: I think this is stuck.
Bob: I think if you can get it over your face-
Amy: Oh that's a DEEP "V"
*all laughing*
Mark: Oh, yeah, that's...Thank you...?
Bob: So I'll just...I'll open them up for you.
Mark: Ahhh, that's a nice "V"...yeah, that- that'd be helpful.
Amy: So if you could just get your arms through, we can...
Mark: Yeah...yoo *grunting*
...just get it over my head... And then...
*all giggling*
*silly voice* I'm a big boy!
Kathryn: *silly voice* I'm a big boy!
Mark: I'm a big boy!  Yaaaah!
Amy: He's ready for Winter snoozing.
*all laughing*
Mark: Ohh, we're going to go to the Game of Thrones launch in this outfit
OOAAAHH...FUCK!!
*all laughing*
*Mark exhales*
Kathryn: Y'know Mark?  For once, your head looks small!
Mark: Thank you!
*all start laughing*
Thank you!
*jokingly* You're so NICE!
You're fired.
*Kathryn and Mark start laughing*
Mark: AHHHHHHHHHAHA!
Kathyrn: I'll Tag In!
Mark & Amy: OK.
Kathyrn: Chica..Just stay in your bed, please, buddy
Mark: Okay...Alright...Okay...
Bob: Oh my gosh!
Mark: I just love putting my arms up in celebration of this.
*Kathryn and Bob laughing*
OOF
You were right. It stayed funny the whole way through
*all start laughing*
Praise the sun...AAAAAhahaha!
*quiet giggling*
Here we go.  This is the last bag.
Bob: This should be...should be nice and big for you
Mark: *scoffs* yeah, okay.
OH!
Bob: Yeah, there you go.
Mark: I keep transitioning, and it's like "Oh..."
Bob: Downright comfortable is what that was...
Mark: *admiring* NICE.  Alright!
Getting this off is going to be...
Amy: *laughing* What's it going to be?
Mark: *low voice*...the biggest bitch...
Bob: The "V" is deepening in the back this time. As opposed to the front
*all start laughing*
Mark: What?
*everybody talking at once*
Bob: It's so far back!
Mark: My "V"!  My fashion!
*Quieter* What happened to me?
Is there a way...that this can make me taller?  If we put all these on and then squeeze really hard will I go up?
Mark: Is this the last one? Bob: Yeah
*girls talking indistinctly*
Mark: Oh, shit, last one, guys!
*grunt*
Kathyrn: Hey, Marshmallow boy.
Mark: YAAAAAAY!
Bob: You're like a pillow!!
*laughing*
Kathryn: ...Like when you pat a dog
Mark: Alright, punch me now
Bob: Can you feel it?  Mark: Barely. Bob: if I punch you you're gonna feel it. Mark: Just light punch.
Mark: No, that's pretty good. Bob: Really? Mark: Yeah
*muffled sound of impact*
Yeah,  it was a pretty good punch
Mark: wOAH *all giggling*
Mark: Alright that one I felt a little bit.
Mark: Yeah, it was like wOAH
Hi there. How's it going? come here often?
Mark: Let's get ONE off.
Mark: Let's see how this works...
Mark: I trust..Woahaah
Kathyrn: You gotta straighten your arms! *all laughing*
Mark: They are st- *garbled*
Bob: It's *laugh* It's still
Kathyrn: 47 to go!! Mark: ooooooohhh GOD
*all laughing* Mark: Alright...
Mark: Let's Try....ok.
Mark: AHh (Everyone Laughs) Mark: Jeez!!
*Mark laughing*
Amy: kay wait, where can we go?
Kathyrn:How are we gonna do this? Amy: Let's do two at a time.  Kathyrn: Yeah.
*Mark grunting, others laughing*
Mark: It's like a squeezing motion. It's so weird!!
Amy: I'm starting to get wet.
[groans]
Bob: are you getting milked right now, Mark?
Mark: yeah a little bit. its a sensation--
*laughter*
oh my god!
Can you see my face get red when that happens?
*everyone sighs, continues laughing*
M: squeeze!
M: im being squoze!
[lots of grunts from mark, and giggles from crew]
A: this is a whole bunch.
M: ok im ready.
here we go
*LOTS of grunts*
M:oh my god!
Amy: its like string cheese!
*laughter*
[amy addressing chat]"the big squeeze"!
M: the big squeeze! alright, here we go!
*Mark grunting*
*pop*
its just the POP
*laughing and unintelligible talking*
*Mark grunting*
A: I feel like I'm drowning you
K: ...we got through the initial layer of crew cuts-
*made unintelligible by laughter*
*laughter, unintelligible*
Mark: Can you date my by this?
*laughter* K: The rings
B: oh god
M: onions have layers!
A: you're so warm!
K: It's getting damp
M: thank you.
[struggling]
A: oh this is the hard part. *Mark grunting*
Mark: Nah, it's getting easier. I could probably take them off by myself this time. Kathryn: Nope, this is more fun
*Mark grunting* Amy: I'm sorry, I'll push you-
Mark: It's ok, I can take it.
Amy: *unintelligible* M: no i dont
K: oH look we found the initial V's!
M: oOOOOH
Let's see if we could take them all off in one go okay, Bob hold my shirt down *laughing*
Bob: Okay. Mark: if it goes up for even a SECOND, im BANNED!
Kathryn: Oh it's SO DAMP!
Here we go!
*grunts and laughing*
*everyone still laughing as Mark lets out pained groans*
*loud laughter*
*everyone still dying of laughter*
*all sigh finally catching breath*... *Mark gasps*
Mark: I'm shook
*Bob giggles*